do you think a cat could survive the
nuclear apocalypse what about a cat any
bulb jumpsuit equipped to the pip-boy
and some flashy goggles from the cat
cosplay Twitter account comes some
images of a cat cosplaying as a fallout
survivor it's wearing a fallout inspired
blue and yellow outfit complete with
goggles and even a pip-boy on its arm
this cat is clearly prepared to survive
in a post-apocalyptic world the image
caption reads if a cat mutates from
radiation will they suddenly have 18 and
a half lives because that would be rad
if you're eager for more feline related
gaming news Metal Gear Solid online
allows you to wear a cat as your head
because why not if you're more concerned
with fallout 4 news there's that too the
first patch is coming out on pc next
week and will follow on ps4 and Xbox one
at a later date oh yeah and the game is
apparently ruining lives relationships
and careers but you probably already
knew that but we have caused playing
cats so there's that for more fallout 4
news you're already in the right place
and be sure to check out our new fallout
show